Hello Freak bitches.
Well,
I saw Ghostbusters,
I didn't see it and I like,
which I feel awful about.
There's some funny shit and Ghostbusters,
like overall it's not a good movie.
This is not a good movie.
But they did some funny shit.
They,
they came up with some fun and
I almost want to know like,
man,
what could this have been if you let
whoever came up with all that funny shit
just make,
make a movie out of it where they
scenes where they died with the dialogue
scenes in dialogue.
There were scenes and it was
such a combination of things.
That movie and it's so had the feeling
of the hands of the producers and the
executives.
It's so handled that
you,
you in some ways,
the thing I liked about Deadpool
was I was watching it going,
the producers of this movie did
a good job where they were like,
this moment doesn't work.
Make it work everyday.
Like micromanage.
Like I worked on Chris
rock movie top five,
a little bit like for a couple of,
I just consulted for a couple of weeks
and the producers is guy named Scott
Rudin who's like a famous producer.
And what I couldn't believe was the level
of detail that guy was worried about.
It was,
he busted Chris's balls for
a year about the script,
literally made them rewrite and rewrite
and rewrite and rewrite and rewrite and
then onset.
The guy was worried about shirts and
buttons and that's what I realized like,
okay,
these dead producers.
Whereas it feels like maybe
on Ghostbusters that got,
you got to get,
you have to get lucky too
with studio where they,
they,
you all haven't agreed to set of,
of what's good and then
you build the movie.
We from there was also this a problem
that the movie had a very clear agenda to
be a pro woman move.
Yeah.
Which it's gets mean.
There's nothing wrong
with being pro woman,
but if that's what,
uh,
it's like,
it's a goofy,
it's not a theme for a movie,
a comedy movie.
It feels
are buffoons.
They're not just buffoons there.
They're cartoonishly retarded.
Yeah.
Like Chris,
whatever the fuck name's
Thor is so retarded.
It doesn't even make sense.
Yeah,
he's,
he's so fucking stupid.
It doesn't make sense.
But they keep them around
because he's beautiful.
And then it's like the joke,
well that's a funny,
but I like it.
These revenge jokes where it's like,
so you're just going to do what men did.
How long is this going to last?
Like what's the next year?
Which is the easy for a man to say like,
Hey,
do something else honey.
But like,
but it just feels like
there's gotta be like a next,
uh,
next.
Uh,
there's a lot of like rep
retribution right now.
What Twitter is,
just wasn't believable.
A lot of what Twitter is,
how it's a lot of people.
It's like digital lynch mobs of
people and that are rightly so.
They'll go after people for saying
something fucked up about race.
Like they went up to Justin Timberlake
a few weeks ago cause he said something
more all the same.
And then it's like,
but you can't say that and it just
becomes this mob of people and it's purely
about racial revenge
as far as I'm concerned.
Well it's,
it's definitely about people
having the opportunity to shit on
and having people that didn't have the
opportunity to before and now they have
it via they,
it's like they have social cachet and
they have social power and they use it for
the same bullshit of
white people use it for,
well,
it's not even just black people doing it.
It's a lot of white people
are on women at any,
any,
any sort of marginalized group,
whether it's poor,
any like literally any group,
this movie like this is,
there's a bunch of
problems with the movie,
but this,
the,
the fact that all the men in
the movie were ridiculous.
All the men this movie were
buffoons all the men in the movie.
Like they like Bill Murray
gets fucking killed in it.
Spoiler alert.
Yeah.
I mean it's weird.
It's weird.
It's like,
yeah,
it's an agenda driven movie more
than they'd wrote something.
They figured,
well,
they'll,
it'll work if you do this or
if it'll work if you do that.
Like they didn't even have
romantic interests in the
movie because men were just
so retarded.
Like the women didn't have boyfriends,
they didn't have husbands.
They didn't have like
they had Chris Hemsworth.
Yeah.
But that's it.
And he was just eye candy.
Well,
the thing
tell people is when you're
writing about a specific gen,
like for a long time,
women in comedy,
women in comedy movies were
a props or they were like,
Andie MacDowell always used to be
like the love interest and in Dallas,
uh,
and she was always just like this warm
sort of like vaguely disapproving.
It's either like you're disapproving of
the guy or you're approving to a fault
because that's,
if you're,
if there's a movie about a certain,
uh,
gender,
which is,
it was usually men,
the women in their lives
for the plot to advance,
they'd even have to be for
the plot or against the plot.
Right.
So then women started complaining like,
well,
you see us as these binary goofy things
and obviously women in life are more
complex than that.
So to now that women are starting to get
their own movies and it's about groups
of women,
you see it,
it's a writing problem.
It's,
you're in a trap where the men and
bridesmaids were goofy as fuck.
It was an Irish cop in Milwaukee.
Tell me more.
Cause I've never seen that
my fucking whole life.
A guy who's just like,
and bridesmaids is a fucking
masterpiece for the most part.
Just that part.
I was kind of like,
wait,
so he's a cop and he's got an endless,
uh,
appetite for wig even though
she's not interested in,
was a,
and was Dicky to him.
But he's still,
he'll take her back,
whatever.
Uh,
and it becomes about,
he's basically the only man in the movie
and it's kind of a goofy part and it's,
well,
it's because it's about a group of women
and that's just the purpose that men
have in that plot.
You know what I mean?
But,
but they always date people take
it as like this a sexism thing.
And I just take it as like
a screenwriting thing.
Well,
it is that definitely,
but one of the problems that people have
found when they're talking this movie
is that you can't criticize it
because if you criticize it,
you're sexist.
Yeah.
And no,
it's not.
It's not a good piece of art.
Yeah.
It's not really well done.
But there's moments who did,
who did bridesmaids
that I'm talking about?
The same guy,
same guy who did it,
he's dead.
Well,
whatever.
He's done it twice now.
But like,
I think he knows he's
a really good writer.
Like he knows you can you,
it's hard to write
because it's never been,
I,
I always tell people,
listen,
I go show me a good example of a,
a movie about a group of guys where
the woman isn't just even in Deadpool,
she's a prop to the,
but they made fun of it or she's
in love with him unconditionally,
even though his face turns into a monster
and she still wants him to eat a pussy
and they make fun of it.
Yeah.
They make fun of it in a funny way.
Like their meetup there meet cute and
then they think about how Gammage they
both are.
That was like perfect to me
cause it was brief and it uh,
it's like the thing they always complain
about when you're developing movies,
like I don't buy this couple.
It's like yeah,
it's fucking movie.
Right.
Sorry.
Just not,
I don't buy a lot of real couples.
Well not only that,
they have to spell it
all out in two hours.
Yeah.
And they have to meet and fall
in love with in five minutes.
Well there's a lot more
to relationships in that.
Yeah.
We can't show you all that other shit.
Cause that takes hours,
days and weeks and months and you fuck,
that is correct.
The sad thing about the movie,
the Ghostbusters movie is there's some
stuff in it that was really clever.
There was funny stuff and I,
in the beginning I was
enjoying it and I was like,
you know what,
I bet people are not given
this thing a fair shake.
And then as it got on and I was like,
oh,
they just,
this is just so clunky.
There's parts of it that were
just so clumsy and just poorly,
poorly got to see it because every single
one of those women are fucking home
run hitters.
Yeah.
Melissa McCarthy is fucking funny,
man.
The Dude,
she's fucking funny wig Kristen wig.
Which one?
She,
uh,
she was in bridesmaids.
I don't know.
I don't know what she's
the Auburn haired woman.
Yeah.
This is Flatley's it fucking monster.
She's,
she's handicapped in it.
They'd give her some clunky lines.
Uh,
and then,
uh,
the girl from SNL,
Kate Mckinnon is really,
really,
she was really fun in it.
She was very funny in it.
It's not that bad.
I mean,
I didn't hate it.
I went to see what my kids,
they enjoyed it.
But um,
there was,
there were some moments
I laughed pretty hard.
Great.
But most of it not.
Yeah.
It's hard to make funny movies,
man.
And you know,
it's like at the end,
they way they wrap it up,
you're like,
oh Christ,
I can't the fuck outta here.
It's like,
it's so clumsy.
Oh,
it's just so awkward.
If somebody told me there
were no stakes in the movie,
it was just like,
yeah,
there's ghosts and we're
going to find them.
We got them.
Yeah.
It is weird.
It's hot fucking mean.
It's funny.
Good movies.
Really hard.
Yeah.
Budget movie.
A big budget with a legacy
and a start and a end.
A release date.
Yeah.
And if they just see,
if there was no Ghostbusters before it,
there'd never been a ghostbuster movie.
And this was the first
ever ghostbuster movie.
There would not,
we wouldn't be talking
about price busters.
It would be different.
Yeah.
Well,
it may be people would enjoy it more and
maybe they wouldn't be so handicapped
because they had to sort of connect with
the legacy and tie all these loose ends
in and they can,
they kind of do it any way,
any way they want.
Okay.